bonjour à tous je m'appelle alexandre
cornillon j'ai 35 ans et je peux vous
dire aujourd'hui que je
suis un homme heureux et surtout un
homme libre depuis je suis tout gamin je
crois que j'ai toujours cherché ma
liberté
sans doute parce que ma mère est née
sous la dictature de salazar au portugal
peut-être aussi sans doute parce que mon
père à la base simple ouvrier dans
l'industrie a gagné sa liberté en créant
une petite entreprise d'électricité la
liberté pour moi c'est faire ce qu'on
veut quand on veut
selon mon interprétation la liberté pour
moi c'est un peu un concept d'enfants
gâtés
j'ai été élevé dans une famille modeste
et on m'a appris qu'en se battant et en
travaillant dur alors on pouvait tout
avoir et pour assouvir ma liberté je me
suis dit que je voulais voyager alors à
18 ans je n'avais qu'un seul rêve
m'installer en australie pour y
développer des projets mais comme
souvent en plein rêve de liberté
cette petite amie vous savez un peu
rabat joie que j'appellerais aujourd'hui
la réalité est venu à moi vous savez
cette petite râleuse la réalité et au
final est bien pour aller faire ses
projets en australie vous vous en rendez
compte
eh bien il me fallait un petit peu
d'argent même beaucoup d'argent pour
pouvoir faire ce voyage
alors j'ai profité de l'entreprise
d'électricité de mon papa pour aller y
travailler
je me suis mis à y travailler même à y
travailler très dur pour gagner de
l'argent et mettre tout cet argent de
côté pour voyager voilà comment j'allais
assouvir mes envies de liberté
et comme j'avais beaucoup d envie de
liberté ben je me suis mis tout
naturellement a beaucoup travaillé a
tellement travaillé qu'il met à devenu
rapidement impossible de me barrer parce
que j'étais devenu indispensable dans
l'entreprise et personne ne pouvait me
remplacer moi c'est ce que je croyais
alors j'ai commencé à réorganiser dans
ma tête mon concept de liberté
si dans l'immédiat je ne pouvais pas
voyager il fallait que je cherche
ailleurs de la liberté sinon j'allais
très vite me sentir aliénés je décide
donc d'avoir plus de liberté dans mon
travail puisque à ce moment là c'est ce
qui occupe toutes mes journées et vous
retrouver ma liberté professionnelle
c'est simple il faut que j'arrête de
passer mon temps à me disputer avec mon
père
il faut que je puisse décider par moi
même ma liberté c'est de pouvoir décider
en psychologie vous avez peut-être
entendu parler on dit souvent il faut
tuer le père pour ma part ça a été
plutôt racheter le père et donc à 22 ans
à l'issue d'une bataille familiale que
je qualifierais de compliqué me voilà à
la tête de l'entreprise d'électricité de
ces vingt collaborateurs et surtout d'un
énorme prêt à rembourser mais dans ma
tête pourtant à cette instance n'était
pas si compliqué si c'est le prix de ma
liberté
alors je vais faire comme on m'a
toujours appris je vais me battre pour y
arriver
j'enchaîne 90 heures par semaine je fais
face aux départs de plusieurs
collaborateurs
je remonte l'activité et je m'octroie
sûr mais quelques heures de temps libre
le début d'une vie qui me faisait rêver
belles voitures grand restaurant grosse
soirée
alcool drogue et filles enfin un peu de
liberté quoi enfin une vie comme à la
télé mais la fête être courte durée car
je me retrouve à m'ennuyer
je me rappelle à mes rêves de voyage et
je décide un truc un peu fou je décide
de réorganiser l'entreprise pour partir
entre quatre à six mois
chaque année ouais 4 à 6 mois comme ça
arbitraire à ce moment là tout le monde
me dit mais tu es fou et je m'en fou et
je le fais à ce jour j'ai fait cette
fois et demi le tour du monde
j'avais donc enfin réussit l'alliance
parfaite entre ma liberté de travail et
la liberté de voyager dont j'avais
toujours rêvé je gagnais de l'argent je
ne me prive de rien je pouvais en
profiter et enfin respirer enfin la vie
rêvée
enfin cette vie rêvée mais celle dont
tout le monde rêvait celle qu'on met
parfois toute une vie à réaliser mais ce
bonheur fut de courte durée
le retour vous savez de mon ami rabat
joie la réalité est en fait j'étais de
nouveau en train de m'ennuyer
j'avais atteint mon objectif et j'avais
besoin
un nouveau défi je comprends à ce moment
là que la liberté une fois gagné ne fait
pas le bonheur pour l'éternité
et me voilà à nouveau dans un intense
besoin de me challenge est alors je me
lance dans une quête insatiable de
création de richesses et de création
d'entreprises dans les quatre années qui
suivent
je crée 10 sociétés me voici embarqués
dans une nouvelle aventure
je me consacre entièrement avec comme
vous l'avez compris toute la modération
qui me caractérise et à 28 ans ça y est
j'ai toujours de quoi m'occuper
suffisamment d'argent pour avoir le
sentiment d'être libre je voyage autant
que je veux j'achète à peu près tout ce
que je veux j'ai donc absolument tout
oui tout pour tomber dans une profonde
dépression qui allait durer trois ans
mais alex tu a tout pour être heureux le
répétait sans cesse mes proches j'avais
peut-être tout mais clairement ça ne me
rendais pas heureux ma santé c'est
également rapidement dégradée j'étais
condamné à subir une opération lourde à
vivre trop intensément je m'était
complètement cramé et à cause de ses
années de négligence
ma vie ne serait plus jamais comme avant
j'étais désormais condamnés à devoir
faire attention tout le temps pendant
ces trois ans j'ai erré dans ma propre
vie sans parvenir à comprendre le sens
de tout ce que j'avais accompli tout ce
qui me paraît si évident quelques mois
auparavant
tout ce pour quoi je mettais battu cette
liberté ce confort de vie m'avait rendu
profondément malheureux alors même que
j'avais toujours fait ce que je voulais
alors je me suis posé cette question
mais comment peut-on être malheureux
quand on a tout ce qu'on veut comment
peut-on être en dépression
quand on a toujours fait comme on
voulait et je me suis pas posée et je me
suis par n'ont posé cette question tous
les jours et dans tous les sens est ce
que j'avais toujours fait comme je
voulais est ce que je savais vraiment ce
que je voulais
à quel moment j'avais rêvé d'être chef
d'entreprise jamais à quel moment
j'avais été heureux avec plus d'argent
jamais pouvoir voyager c'était génial
mais au fond pourquoi faire j'ai
commencé à réaliser que j'avais pris
pour des libertés toutes les initiatives
personnage avait pris ça pour de la
liberté
en fait j'ai pris conscience que tout ça
était le fruit incalculable d'un nombre
de paramètres qui avait conduit ma
pensée à imaginer que ça c'était de la
liberté je vous donne un exemple mon
éducation
les films la télévision les informations
les proches
tout ce que j'avais toujours pensé
n'était en fait que l'interprétation de
ce que d'autres pensaient mais à quel
moment j'avais pensé par moi même à quel
moment j'avais pensé sans avoir peur du
jugement
à quel moment j'avais essayé de savoir
ce qui me plaisait vraiment à moi et
durablement
à 30 ans je me suis rendu compte que
tout ce que j'avais accompli jusque là
rien je vous dis bien rien ne me
plaisait réellement rien et à trop
courir après la libère après l'idée que
je me faisais de la liberté j'en avais
même oublié de me demander ce qui me
rendait heureux moi même au delà des
codes de la société au delà du regard et
de la vie des autres
alors j'ai pris une décision radicale
contre l'avis de tous de mes proches de
mon entourage j'ai pris la décision de
revendre toutes les parts de mes
entreprises et de tout arrêter parce que
j'en avais la certitude désormais elle
ne m'apporterait ni liberté ni bonheur
j'ai créé quelque chose de plus fort que
l'argent j'ai créé une association
caritative
cette association s'appelle les routes
du bonheur qui aide des jeunes enfants
handicapés des jeunes enfants autistes
des jeunes enfants trisomiques ou des
jeunes enfants atteints d'un handicap
mental à avoir des interactions sociales
avec les vingt bénévoles de
l'association
on permet à ces jeunes
de partir des projets un peu fous vous
allez voir un une semaine par an les
emmène sur les routes de haute savoie
on les accompagne
on leur fait visiter des endroits
magnifiques on a des interactions
magique on apprend à les connaître et
surtout on apprend à les aimer et
aujourd'hui s'il ne me restait que
quelques heures à vivre cette
association serait la seule chose la
seule et unique chose dont j'aimerais
qu'on se souvienne la seule première
chose dont je suis réellement fier dans
tout ce que j'ai fait de ma vie pour
mesurer la réussite pour mesurer la
fierté l'accomplissement
il y avait donc quelque chose de plus
fort et de plus grand que l'argent il y
avait la qualité des interactions
l'intensité du bonheur qu'on partage
avec les autres et j'avais gaspillé
toutes ces années à ne pas en profiter
et si alors tout ce qu'on m'avait dit
étaient toutes à foutu ramassis de
conneries finalement et si j'étais passé
à côté de tant de belles choses et si la
seule solution c'était de recommencer de
revoir l'ensemble des codes de mes codes
des codes de la société et de renaître
et si je pouvais repartir à zéro on nous
dit qu'au xxième siècle on doit être
connectés et informés de tout ce qui se
passe j'ai décidé pour ma part depuis
bientôt six ans de couper la télévision
je n'ai aucun réseau social je ne suis
aucune actualité j'ignore la quasi
totalité de ce qui se passe dans le
monde on nous dit qu'il faut aux trois
repas et un litre d'eau par jour pour
être en bonne santé et bien pour ma part
je ne prends qu'un repas par jour je
jeûne une fois par semaine et deux fois
une semaine par an je la passe sans
boire ni manger
pas de liquide pas de nourriture pas
même de l'eau et vous savez quoi
ma santé s'est amélioré alors j'ai
continué et je me suis dit tout ce que
j'avais acheté ces vingt dernières
années
je m'en suis débarrassé je l' ai tout
simplement donner à des gens qui en
avaient besoin
est ce que j'avais besoin de 40 assiette
chez moi alors que je peux pas
accueillir
deux villes invitées est-ce que c'était
sorèze à salade
ces vêtements ou tous ces trucs
conserver au cas où était sorti de mes
armoires ces cinq dernières années
avait-il une autre vocation que celle de
s'entasser je pratique aujourd'hui le
contentement
je me pose chaque jour du temps pour
prendre conscience de la chance que j'ai
d'avoir ce que j'ai et d'être là où je
suis la chance tout simplement d'avoir
un toit chaque soir quand je me couche
car dans les nombreux voyages que j'ai
faits les gens que j'ai rencontrés tout
le monde dans le monde n'a pas cette
chance d'avoir à manger je n'achète plus
de nourriture pour une semaine car il
met trop arrivée de gaspiller et de
jeter pour l'avoir vécu je peux vous le
dire aujourd'hui consommation égale
dépression d'ailleurs une statistiques
le prouvent les pays les plus riches
sont aussi et surtout ceux qui
consomment le plus d'antidépresseurs
je vous laisserai faire vos propres
conclusions là dessus je me suis
appliqué une règle stricte
dès que j'ai une envie spontanée
d'acheter quelque chose est bien
j'attends six mois et puis je me dis si
dans six mois
j'ai encore envie de l'acheter eh bien
je l'achète et bien croyez moi je
parviens très bien me passer de 95 % de
mes envies éphémère qui sont dictées par
le marketing
ces 5 % restants ce que j'achète
vraiment ma vous savez quoi evin j'en
profite à fond je suis très heureux de
les avoir
j'ai cessé de m'offrir des plaisirs
inutile et éphémère
j'ai également cesser de consommer les
relations humaines
je me suis recentré sur les quelques
personnes qui sont importantes pour moi
j'ai pris le temps d'appeler toutes les
autres pour leur dire que je coupais le
contact et que j'arrêtais je m'en fous
complètement d'être aimé je veux juste
des interactions de qualité et que
celles ci soient partagées fait un prêt
immobilier
marie toi fais des enfants tous ces
impératifs de société qu'on va sans
cesse répétées et peut-être que certains
d'entre vous à qui ça parle
est ce que tous ces impératifs de
société contribue-t-il vraiment à mes
envies
est-ce que c'est impératif de société
corresponde vraiment un monde
honneur à mon objectif moi j'ai une
réponse pour moi en tout cas absolument
pas alors pourquoi accepter ces pseudos
impératif si je ne suis pas d'accord
et si je ne ressens pas si je n'en
ressens pas le besoin par non pour faire
plaisir à qui pourquoi devrais-je
renoncer à mon libre arbitre
aujourd'hui encore je continue à
remettre en cause chaque petit détail de
ma vie à déconstruire tous les préjugés
et tout ce que je pourrai encore sans
m'en rendre compte me laisser dicter les
impératifs de la société ne sont
tellement profondément ancrée que l'on
en a oublié de doute et on a oublié de
chercher qui on était vraiment et ce
qu'on voulait vraiment on a tous une
définition différente du bonheur de
l'amour de la réussite de la joie on a
tous une interprétation qui nous est
personnel cette personnalisation de
chaque aspect de ma vie j'ai mis 35 ans
à comprendre à quel point elle est
précieuse et à quel point elle m'est
propre à quel point j'ai le pouvoir
d'agir et de décider à quel point aucun
préjugé n'est justifiée et à quel point
je ne dois laisser à personne
le pouvoir de contrôler mon existence à
ma place aujourd'hui tout n'est pas
parfait
j'ai encore des défauts des failles des
angoisses des questions mais aujourd'hui
enfin ma vie m'appartient et je sais
maintenant que je m'étais trompé de
bonheur merci à tous
[Applaudissements]